[Musique]
c'est la onzième édition de tech'innove
donc c'est une manifestation convention
d'affaires qui a été organisée par la
cci essonne depuis 2007 12 cette 11e
édition et qui réunit
sur un même endroit et dans un seul jour
trois conventions une convention
d'affaires donc qui réunit donneur
d'ordres est preneur d'ordres une
convention de laboratoire enfin r&d qui
réunit donc des laboratoires et des pme
qui sont intéressés par les recherches
effectuées dans ses laboratoires et une
convention de financement
donc on a des jeunes pousses qui sont en
recherche de fonds propres pour un
premier tour de financement de ces trois
conventions permettent en fait aux
participants de d'afficher un programme
de rendez vous lors de rendez vous
qualifiés c'est ça tout l'intérêt de
cette manifestation c'est que en fait
aussi bien
celui qui demande que celui qui reçoit
ont décidé de se rencontrer pour un
intérêt commun
cette année nous avons fait une
innovation particulière c'est à dire on
a créé un startup challenge puisque
effectivement un grand focus est donné
sur les start up qui sont l'avenir de
notre développement économique
et ces startups donc on fait candidature
pour ce challenge qui réunit maintenant
26 start up sur trois thématiques
mobilité énergie et objets connectés
nous avons sélectionné 26 start up pour
venir pitcher dans une salle qui leur
est dédié devant un parterre dans
d'entreprises intéressées non seulement
elle pitch mais en plus elles ont été
préparées accompagner pour effectivement
maximiser finalement l'impact de leurs
messages aujourd'hui tech'innove
c'est plus de 900 structure donc pme
grands groupes laboratoires qui sont
réunis aujourd'hui c'est plus de 1700
personnes
et dans ces 900 structure il ya 400 pme
160 grands groupes 80 laboratoires
donc autant de structures qui trouvent
un intérêt à se réunir ensemble au même
endroit et en même temps
[Musique]